When I began my career in cancer research,
really,
nothing was known about how the disease arises,
and now we know exactly why cancer occurs.
We don't know all the causes,
which is a problem,
but we do know that once those causes have done their job,
all cancer arises from the malfunction of genes.
When I arrived to take up my position at University of
California,
San Francisco,
I met Warren Levinson,
who was another newly recruited young scientist who had been
trained to study Rous sarcoma virus.
Now Rous sarcoma virus was discovered by Peyton
Rous at the turn of the 20th century,
and was the first tumor virus ever described
to any credible level.
It was a historic discovery,
and it was utterly neglected for over fifty years. This was a chicken virus;
this virus was discovered in chickens originally. And did it bother me that it was a chicken virus?
Not at all.
I was a great believer in what we call the universality of nature,
and if I could find out anything about cancer in a chicken,
I knew it would apply to humans.
And boy,
was I right.
The biological effects were dramatic.
You could take normal chicken fiberglass in a Petri dish,
put Rous sarcoma virus on it, on those cells,
and within 24 hours,
their whole phenotype changed,
their appearance changed, their replicative behavior changed to be more aggressive.
They started crawling over each other in a chaotic
manner, like cancer cells can do.
And,
of course,
if you put the virus into a chicken,
it would also get a tumor.
That's what Rous had originally done,
that's how he discovered the virus.
He took a tumor, lysed the cells,
put it through a filter to take out any living cells,
put that lysate, or filtrate as we called it,
into chickens, and they would get the same tumor.
And then he could make extracts from that tumor,
filter it, put it in another chicken, and get a tumor again.
Hence,
Rous sarcoma virus. Another very important discovery that was made was
overshadowed to an unfortunate extent by the discovery of reverse
transcriptase.
And that was a discovery, made by Steven Martin at the University of California,
Berkeley,
that Rous sarcoma virus had at least one gene,
and it turned out to be only one gene, that was responsible for the tumorigenic
capacity of the virus.
And that brings me to Harold Varmus,
who joined me as a colleague in 1970, the year that reverse
transcriptase was discovered and two years after I started my work at
UCSF. Harold joined me in an
extremely informal process.
He had been a postdoctoral fellow at the National Institutes
of Health and had taken a
course in tumor viruses.
He was working at the time with phage and bacteria.
And I think about five minutes into the conversation,
I decided we ought to get this guy in the lab because he was obviously very smart
and we were on the same wavelength scientifically;
we wanted to do molecular biology on the virus and we shared other
interests,
cultural interests,
particularly literary interests.
We decided that we ought to look for src in normal cells.
Now,
this was well before recombinant DNA.
If we'd had recombinant DNA,
we could have done the subsequent experiments in a few months.
As it is,
it took four years.
And here we were helped again by genetics.
Peter Vogt,
a longstanding collaborator of ours,
Peter Vogt was a master of the biology of these viruses and the genetics.
And he had isolated mutants in Rous sarcoma virus
that were deletions of src.
So we had available to us the deletion mutant, which had
no src or a very little piece of src in it,
and of course,
we had the full Rous sarcoma virus genome with src in it.
So the idea was that we would copy, use reverse transcriptase to
copy the genome of Rous sarcoma virus into radioactive DNA,
and then we would use the deletion mutant to fish, to pull out,
by molecular hybridization,
we would use the deletion mutant to pull out all of the nucleotide
sequences of the replicated genes, and leave
the src nucleotides in the residue,
if you will.
It worked like a charm.
It was hard work.
The first hints that it would work came from a postdoctoral
fellow named Ramareddy Guntaka,
but he had a full blown project well underway,
and once he had shown that we could probably make a probe this way,
we recruited another postdoctoral fellow, Dominique Stehelin,
to run with it and he did, in spades.
We began to make this src specific probe, we were able to demonstrate
its specificity in a variety of ways.
He was able to make this probe consistently,
and to use it, and soon found
that the probe would react with normal chicken DNA.
If you want to use the probe
to assess the presence of the sequences in the probe in DNA,
you first have to take the DNA apart,
denature it as they say,
the strands separate,
and then you put the radioactive probe in there and you allow the
strands to reassociate. And the radioactive probe gets
taken up in the mix.
So although the bulk of the DNA will reassociate with its unlabeled
original compliment,
some of it will re-anneal with the radioactive probe.
There was something in the DNA of normal avian cells that was homologous
to the oncogene, the cancer gene, of Rous sarcoma virus.
We called it cell src for the sake of the argument.
If you fiddled with the reaction conditions,
the probe would react with DNA from any avian species we tested,
including the most primitive species,
such as ostrich or the so called ratite, the ostrich,
the emu, the rhea. Incidentally, it was not easy to come by the DNA for
these creatures,
but we managed one way or another.
I vividly remember the morning that Dominique brought
us the first positive results.
They'd come in a late Saturday evening when Harold and I,
who were in a partnership at the time that lasted for fifteen years,
first saw the data.
I was dumbfounded.
I recognize that this was heretical
discovery and that we were going to have to construct an
airtight argument.
So I think I was a little less enthusiastic than Dominique would have liked because he was beside
himself with excitement.
But Harold and I both understood from the get go that if this was real,
we were looking, we were looking at a possible
entrée to the very fundamental underpinning of cancer.
By the time I gave my Nobel lecture,
I had a slide with something like thirty retroviral
oncogenes,
each of which had a demonstrable proto-oncogene
progenitor,
if you will,
in normal cells. And as the number mounted,
it became clear that here was, here was the makings of
a unifying theory of cancer.
And we were cautious about how we
stated that publicly at first,
but by the early 80s,
I was using that term, unifying theory, of how
all cancers come about.
It was a gradually building thrill to
realize that we had the cancer cell by the neck, in terms of
understanding it,
not in terms of throttling it,
but in terms of understanding it.